So, here I am, applying to be one of your interns...
...because the more I think about this idea, the more tremendous I think it is.
I love the idea of having a place I can go every day.
I want the connection,  the excitement, I want to be challenged...
...and I guess I might even want to be needed.
The tech stuff might take a bit to figure out.
I had to call my nine-year-old grandson just to find out what a USB connector was.
But, I'll get there, eager to learn.
Also, I want you to know, I've been a company man all my life.
I'm loyal, I'm trustworthy and I'm good in a crisis.
And I love that you're right here in Brooklyn.
I've lived here all my life, and lately, I feel I may not be hip enough to live in Brooklyn.
So, this could help with that, too.
I read once, "Musicians don't retire."
"They stop when there's no more music in them."
Well, I still have music in me.
Absolutely positive about that.